what's our first question today is from
Maria Maria in Joshua Tree California
you my name is Maria I'm from Joshua
Tree California I had a quick question
for you guys I have a very difficult
relationship with my parents they are
unsupportive of many of my lifestyle
choices and values my partner minimalism
my drive to be debt-free my hobby is
being a pet owner so often I hear Josh's
Maxim you can't change the people around
you but you can change the people around
you does this apply to my parents should
there be a finality or an ending a
discussion therapy is it even worth the
time and effort it would take to try and
fix this awful relationship that has
been going on for my entirety of my
adult life how did both of you find it
within yourselves to forgive your
parents for all their shortcomings any
help would be appreciated thank you very
much and thank you for continuing this
wonderful podcast it brings value each
never leaks my life man I I just want to
throw a disclaimer out there this entire
episode I can't I can speak only from my
perspective right and I feel like I've
done a lot of things right when it comes
to difficult relationships on supportive
relationships but I also think I've done
a lot of stuff wrong okay so I would
definitely I will definitely share that
and own up to it so I guess I'm just
saying this for our listeners because
you know take what I say with a grain of
salt because it is my perspective and
and learn from the mistakes that I have
made in past toxic relationships you can
isolate that a little bit and apply that
to anything that we ever talked that
straight that's true
so specifically this man it's like
because there's some hard in in in
Moorea situation here I mean this is a
really her question was is how how have
we forgiven our parents for all of their
their shortcomings and like for me it's
it hasn't been this process of
forgiveness it's really been this
process of letting go well let's talk
about forgiving for a second because
that's important she ended her question
with that but I think quite often we
forgive not for the other people we
forgive for us that is
that's sort of the first step in
allowing us to let go in the sort of
acceptance process yeah quite often it's
about forgiving the folks in our lives
not for them they don't sometimes they
don't even need to know that we forgave
them mm-hmm sometimes they can't know
that we forgive them sometimes like with
my mother passing on I'm not my father
passing on they don't know that I've
forgiven them at this point well mom dad
we and we could talk about that her last
year here but that forgiving was
partially so I could come to terms with
the imperfections that we're going on
the the lack of acceptance you're saying
you're saying forgiveness is part of the
healing process I think so I mean so a
few things that I would ask Ryan is with
Maria here is have you asked for their
support I mean sometimes I think it just
comes down to have you been able to ask
for their support and then can you show
them what that support would look like
because you can't just say hey I need
you to support me mm-hmm what does that
mean because well support to them it
might mean one thing support to them I
mean well we're always going to make it
really difficult for you because we
think that's how you are going to grow
yeah right we're going to hold you to
our standards instead of your standards
can you show them what your standards
are and why that's important yeah for
you to just say oh I need help and then
like if I just sent you a text hey Josh
I need help period oh yeah you'd be like
great I'm happy to help you right but in
which way do you need help exactly and
so sometimes but but here's the other
thing so so what if I actually didn't
need help but I was saying that I needed
help and so the question I would ask
Maria here is do you actually need their
support or what kind of support do you
need from them maybe it's not what you
think you need maybe what you actually
need isn't what you think you need and
if you do need some support I totally
get it
why do you need that someone yeah you
know it's funny men the in a perfect
world you know family it would be it
would be people who are closer to you
than your closest friends
in a perfect world and I think the idea
that I have that that's what family
should be it has made me kind of in the
same position Maria is where I feel like
I should be getting all of this support
and I feel like I should have really
awesome parents and I've gone out of my
way to support them and I've gone out of
my way to to live a meaningful life and
show them by example I should have you
know this amazing relationship with my
parents right and what what I have come
to realize is that I don't deserve
anything like I am not entitled to
anything that's the house of cards
member you are entitled to nothing when
he took away Social Security yeah
but the weird thing is then he sort of
handing out entitlements after that but
but but he the one thing he said was hey
you're not entitled to anything I think
it's a good reminder because when we
start to have this mentality of here's
what I deserve here's what I should have
yeah here's the way my life should be
going your life should not be going
anyway it becomes a slippery slope right
because I think about like ice cream
well I've had a good week this week I
deserve an ice cream no I don't deserve
an ice cream if I want to have one then
that's my decision
it's probably not a good decision but
but the truth is that I don't deserve
anything other than the fundamental
rights of kindness and and well I
deserve to be left alone and not have
people you don't barge into my house in
the middle of the night or something but
but for the most part we don't just
deserve all of these extras that we
these are just expectations yeah dude I
mean we can live the most meaningful
life possible and then walk outside and
get hit by a bus right
I mean life happens to us whether we're
doing the right things or not I think
that when we do the right things and we
try to put our best foot forward and we
try to respect appreciate accept others
for their in differences I think that
will help us to have better results but
there's nothing in life that says we
must have awesome results if we're
putting in this kind of effort
you know it's funny you say that I we I
was walking in the office today and I
almost stepped in this giant pile of dog
poop and I barely avoided it right and I
was just having I was having a rough
morning like I was really tired and like
I was trying to get my bag packs I'm
gonna ready take a trip right after this
and man like I think I realized right
but as I missed the dog poop I'm like oh
this morning could be way worse I could
have stepped in [ __ ] like and and
it's to me that III need to remember
that sometimes like it can always be
worse no matter what situation you're in
yeah you could add [ __ ] it's not so
funny if I was still gonna be worse I
was thinking to myself man if I stepped
in [ __ ] if I like literally stepped
in [ __ ] I'd be like oh well it could
have been worse I could've stepped in
gum yeah I know what you say mitt well
you know here's here's what I have
learned Maria
is that the word family at least in my
experience it really hasn't meant
anything what what family has meant in
in my experience with a lot of my family
members I'm trying to not like just make
a blanket statement here because I have
really really awesome really supportive
family members who would go to the ends
of the earth for me the ends of the Flat
Earth I'm just joking but no seriously
like people who get wet are the way for
me so I'm not I'm not making this a
blanket statement for all my family
members but what I'm saying is that
there are certain family members who
view the term family as I can treat you
however I want and you have to love me
because I'm your family member or worse
some family members have greater
expectations of me because I'm their
family member but then like the other
meaning they have greater expectations
like um oh let me speak from my
perspective people treat me this way but
let me let me specifically say from my
perspective how I've done this in the
past so with my one of my sisters like
she was that she was like you know this
little innocent
you know my little tiny sister and I
like just had her in this bubble this
this you know her the idea of her was
like she was in this bubble on
uncorruptible pure and then you know I
find out she's drinking and and and you
know smoking dope and doing all the
things that I was doing one out when I
was her age but but because she was my
sister like I had this very visceral
feeling of like how much she has let me
down because this thing that you this
expectation you had of this pristine
right person but there are plenty of
people who I hang out with who drink and
smoke right I still drink alcohol and
I'll still smoke and it's it's it's
something that it's not it's it's a it's
a one-way street with that attitude like
you don't like smoke cigarettes no no
I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah yeah but but
yeah I guess what well I mean I've sure
I've had a cigarette in the last 10
years or something but my point is my
point is this yeah is that I am judging
her for behavior that I've done for
behavior that that I might I guess I
guess I don't currently do it but my
point is is that judging her for
something that I was doing at her age
and raising her standards but not my own
oh I think that is I think that is the
effect that I'm talking about that that
certain family members will have they
will raise their standards for you but
not for everyone else in their life or
themselves or I should say not family
members in their life does that make
sense yeah but so we've talked about
standards the other thing I think we
need to talk about here is values right
and so realize that you might have
different either values or beliefs now
if you have different values from your
parents
Maria then I think that yes it's
important to recognize that you just
have different values from them and if
they judge you judge you then their
judgment is simply a mirror that
reflects their own values that are
different from yours now that said they
might just have different beliefs from
you and the same values if they have
different beliefs that's just a
different path to get to the same place
to get to those
same values and I think you have to
recognize that the only way to recognize
that though is to get really clear on
what your values are my partner Rebecca
and I will sit down often and go over
our own values to see what's the same
what's different how can we improve how
can we raise our standards together so
that we're serving and supporting each
other's values in fact on her website
Sean have you put a link to this in the
show notes podcast Sean I'd appreciate
that
it's her website too minimal
wellness.com if you go to slash values
on her website she did this leg well
together we kind of we put this together
those values worksheet I guess you call
take a little one-page thing to help you
identify what your values are and it's
helped me and her make sure that we are
on the same page even when we value
something differently or if we have the
same value but one of us value something
more than someone else you go back to
episode 69 as well I'll put a link to
that and in the show notes too we did an
entire episode on values and getting
clear on what your values are because it
isn't until you're clear on that so you
know what they are that you can figure
out how you raise your standards
appropriately otherwise you're just sort
of walking around blindly searching and
you're constantly trying to and this
sounds like what what's happening here
trying to live up to someone else's
expectations someone else's values now
you and I did this a lot in our 20s
right and I think that's especially true
with people we've looked up to our
entire lives our parents where they try
to instill their values in us and quite
often that can be a good thing if we're
provided with the right template but
they also instill their beliefs in us
and those aren't necessarily our beliefs
and quite often they instill their their
desires of their preferences in us I
think about Serena Williams Venus and
Serena Williams they're their father I
think we had them playing tennis when
they were three years old yeah and I
mean thankfully that worked out with
them but think about how many other
parents are like forcing their kids to
play the sport that they succeeded at or
maybe didn't succeed to succeed at yeah
yeah because that's their their desire
isn't actually your desire yeah man you
know Maria if if you have gone out of
your way
if she has gone out of her way to to ask
for her parents support
mm-hm and she has you know kind of
clearly said here's the support I need
here's the actions that I am I'm asking
if you're willing to do and they are
still in constant opposition of her
living a meaningful life I mean in my
case with with my dad for example it's a
very similar situation to Maria's I
constantly have opposition from him when
it comes to the life that I live and
every time I spoke to him it was it was
a reminder of how I'm letting him down
it was a reminder of how he doesn't
agree with my lifestyle it was a
reminder of how him and I will never
have this amazing relationship that I
really really want and part of it has to
do some fundamental beliefs that he has
with respect to religion sure that are
definitely different from your own
beliefs yeah and and you know ultimately
I don't believe the same things that he
believes right and I don't follow the
same organization that he's follows and
because of that he has created division
in our relationship he did this a year
ago two years ago where he called me up
and he's like hey son you know I was
just talking to Marilyn might that's my
stepmom and you know she pointed out to
me how I'm not gonna go into details
with dogmatix and stuff but ultimately
she pointed out to me how we shouldn't
even be having dinner with you we
shouldn't be even having having a meal
with you yeah and if you need if you
need an something from me or if you have
an emergency please reach out to me I'm
here for you
but other than that don't talk to me so
um for four years I was for the last
year - I was living in this limbo like
on the fence of is my dad gonna cut me
off altogether or is he ever going to
like treat me like you know like this
relationship like it's a normal
father-son relationship and ultimately
the relationship
right and ultimately he's not he he is
he is basically using our relationship
as leverage to get me to to do exactly
what he wants and you know whether he's
coming from a good place or not I think
you know he can look in the mirror and
say oh I'm coming from a good place but
he's not considering me at all in that
situation so in this situation you know
a few weeks ago I called I called him up
I actually wrote him an email and I just
said hey look man I really really don't
like the way that you're treating me and
I have tried for a long time to - you
know flatten this relationship out and
like you know get it nice and smooth and
you are constantly reminding me how
we're never gonna have the relationship
that I really want so I have to have a
funeral for this relationship I have to
you know literally accept the fact that
my dad and I will never ever ever have
that father-son relationship that I so
so deeply desire yeah I still have hope
that maybe one day hold you know maybe
he's like he has amnesia or something
and he'll hit his head and like you know
come to a senses I don't you don't have
that expectation but I do not have that
expectation so I still I still do hold
onto a little bit of hope don't get me
wrong but you know ultimately I had to
cut off all communication with my father
because anytime I communicated with him
it was it was literally direct
opposition to me living a meaningful
life and I think when it comes down to
people in our life who are in constant
opposition even if it's half the time
half opposition you know you have the
the the ability to say hey you know what
you are constantly not supporting me in
fact you're doing the opposite of
supporting me you're trying to tear me
down and I really need you to not tear
me down and if they continue to to tear
you down then there's got to be a
certain something has to give right yeah
so for me yeah like I have I have
decided to
stop the the the stop being in limbo I
have taken myself out of limbo with this
relationship and I've had a funeral for
what I know is probably not ever going
to happen I think that's a great way to
put it I mean because you you also did
the work you because it's not just
explaining the what like here are my
values your explain you've also done the
work to explain why these are your
values and so for Maria the thing that
she needs to also understand is she can
say well being debt-free is one of my
values but if your parents don't
understand why that is a value or or
living a a simple life is one of your
values if you just say the what that's
that's the start that's the first step
but you got to explain the why and I
know you and I know your father really
well and I know you've gone through the
work of explaining know why and also how
it has made you a better person for
simplifying your life and and walking
away from from your dogmatic years of
youth and and how that philosophy that
Dogma was no longer serving you in fact
it was an impediment toward the
meaningful life that you wanted to live
now with many people it's they don't
have to take it as far as having a
funeral for the ideal relationship they
hope to have but I think it's important
to know and I'm glad you shared that
because it's it is an option because
sometimes the best way that you can love
somebody is from a distance
you